Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Roderick Bitton. He's Emeritus
Cis Professor of Modern Greek and Byzantine History, Language
and Literature at King's College London, and today we're
going to talk about his book Europe A New
History. So Dr. Bitten, welcome to the show. It's
a big pleasure to everyone. Well,
thank you for having me. I'm looking forward to
talking to you.
So just before we get into uh talking about
uh how a European identity developed uh across history,
uh, I would like to start with a sort
of a methodological question here. So tell us about
the branch of history known as history of ideas
that in the book you mentioned, you draw from.
Well, I do, because the book is, you know,
is as well as being a history of Europe
is in terms of things that have happened and
people who have made things happen. It's also, uh,
I also tried to write the story of the
idea of Europe. And As I, as I mentioned,
as you say, I, um, you know, I, I,
the context for doing that is the broad area
of academic study called the history of ideas and.
As I understand it, I mean, this is where
the traditional disciplines of philosophy and history, uh, really
intersect, just as we have the, you know, there's
a well developed, uh, Branch of uh academia known
as the the history of science, you know, how
discoveries got made, who made them, in what context
and so on. And the history of ideas, if
you like, is a, is a broader version of
the, uh, of the history of science. A lot
of the people who work in that area, um,
uh, work on the 18th century European Enlightenment because,
you know, that was a time when actually, you
know, people became interested in abstract ideas. Um, AND,
uh, and, and, you know, began to develop a
historical perspective, uh, on them. And it turns out
that within the history of ideas, the idea of
Europe is an idea that people have, uh, you
know, have, um, have discussed quite a lot. And
As I was, as far as I was able
to discover, it's this really goes back to a
professor at the University of Edinburgh in the middle
of the 20th century, Dennis Hay, who wrote an
excellent short book on the history of the idea
of Europe. And in recent years, uh, there are
many academics, uh, some in, in the humanities, in
literature study in philosophy, who've really taken up this
idea further. So what I'm trying to do in
my book is to bring together. What you might
call uh narrative history, conventional history, uh, history of
events with the history of of the idea of
Europe specifically seen in that kind of uh in
that kind of framework.
Right, so when we talk about the European identity,
when exactly did it first originate, or I mean,
is it even possible for us to answer that
question about when it first originated?
Well, I believe that it is very specifically that
um as an idea, as an identity, it it
it emerged in the middle of the 5th century
BCE. And it emerged in the wake of the,
the Great War, series of wars between the small
city-states of the ancient Greeks, and the empire of
the Medes and Persians in the Middle East, which
at that time was the largest empire that the
world had ever seen. And, you know, as many
people know, in that kind of epic contest, it
was kind of David and Goliath contest. And, you
know, against all expectations, the, um, you know, the
tiny Greek city-states won out over the mighty juggernaut
of the Persian Empire. And it was in the
wake of that victory that the Greeks who had
won, really began to take stock of all, you
know, how this had happened, what, what they'd managed
to do. It was a kind of, you know,
a kind of gosh moment. And Many things happened
during the century that followed that that that uh
victory, um, much of what we call ancient Greek
civilization. But a small part of that, a very
specific part of it, to my mind, was the
writing of history by one man, Herodotus of Halicarnassus.
Who was born about the time, uh, just before
the, uh, the, the final episode in that war.
He's born about 484 BCE and, uh, in the
middle of the century, about 447 BCE he began
writing his history to explain all the things that
happened. And it's really thanks to Herodotus that we
know, um, as much as we so much about
these these particular, uh, particular wars. I hone in
on something very specific that Herodotus picks out in
his explanation for those wars. He goes to some
trouble to explain that it was a war between
not just what we might call civilizations. The war
between continents. And according to Herodotus, he kind of
weaponizes the geographical separation that the Greeks had become
used to. It's traditional for them. They had drawn
a Greek geographical separation between Europe on the one
side of the the sea where they lived, and
Asia on the other. And according to Herodotus, it
was kind of the gods themselves. And he even
claims that the Persians themselves believed that their homeland
where they belonged was Asia. And therefore, it was
a kind of insult to the gods for the
Persians to try to usurp, you know, rule over
another continent. And I don't, you know, I don't
think this is what happened. I don't think the
Persians had any idea that there was another continent
across these straits, across that sea. It was Herodotus'
idea that, you know, we Europeans on his side,
were actually fighting to defend a whole continent. And
in that way, Europe, which had previously been simply
a geographical uh line on a map, became weaponized
as an identity that people could fight and die
for. And the perhaps extraordinary consequence of that is
that actually, through the influence of the written word
of Herodotus, that idea and that identity. Have continued
with many changes, but nonetheless have continued in a
traceable form from that time to this, making it
a story of 2.5 1000 years.
So how does the idea of Europe relate to
the idea of the West and what people tend
to think as being Western society or Western culture?
This is a big subject and it's actually a
favorite subject of mine. Um, THERE'S a marvelous book
by a colleague of mine, uh, Georgios, uh, Varouakis,
um, called The West, The History of an Idea,
and you were asking about history of ideas. I
mean, Georgios is a, is a specialist in the
history of ideas, and he's written a brilliant book
about the history of the West in which. He
states categorically, and he's absolutely right, that the West
was never a concept for people like, you know,
Socrates or Plato or Cicero or Charlemagne, you know,
right through European history. The West was an idea,
it was a construct that, uh, Yorios dates it
to the 1840s. So it's a very recent idea.
And I actually go further than Yorios Varouzakis in,
in believing that. The West as a geopolitical active
concept dates from as recently as the 1940s. Because
the, to my mind, you know, the West, this
idea of an American-led hegemony over a large part
of the world. This was a kind of fig
leaf for uh America's emergence as a superpower. And
it made sense during the confrontation during during the
Cold War with uh Soviet Russia, which was easily
seen as a geographical east. But after the end
of the Cold War, the West, I believe, you
know, disappears as a, as a concept. And of
course, the recent, uh, the stance of the recent
of the of the current administration in the United
States, um, has very much, you know, exploded. You
know, it, it's really shown for what it was,
that construct is an artificial construct, the West, to
my mind, The history of what we call the
West, you know, Western domination or Western Empire, uh,
the West, you know, allegedly triumphed over the rest
of the world. Um, I don't believe it did,
by the way. But, you know, that triumph triumphalist
story is actually not the story of the West
at all. Um, IT'S a story of Europe. It
was Europe that went out and made its mark
over so much, so much of the rest of
the world. And I also believe that that happened
for very specific reasons, which we may come on
to that, you know, during the 14th, 15th century,
Europe was under intense pressure from the Islamic world
to the east. And that was a motivation for
Europe to sort of take, take, you know, take
off across the Oceans. But I do believe, you
know, there is a story to be told about
how it's actually not the West that made the
made its impact on the rest of the world.
It was Europe. And I, let me be honest,
I just wish I could sell that idea to
a publisher. I have tried.
So, uh, but nowadays, of course we're going to
come back to the history of this idea, but
nowadays when people refer to Europe, what do they
mean by it exactly? Are they referring to a
geographical region with particular limitations? Are they referring to
a political identity? Are they referring to an ethnic
identity? At the end, if so, then that would
have a genetic element to it, uh, all of
the above, none of the above.
Well, I mean, all of, I mean, the short
answer is, of course, you know, all of the
above, but one of the reasons I wrote my
book is that it seemed to me that a
lot of the people in, you know, people in
politics, in public discourse who were talking about Europe,
um, as they do, as they have been an
awful lot in the last 10 years, actually don't
know themselves. And I would like to think that
this book would help to sort of pin down
or at least provide the historical basis to help
people formulate what actually they do understand by when
they talk of Europe, because. OK, I mean, at
the, at one level, it is, is geographical, it
is lines on a map. Um, AND in many
ways those lines are clear. Europe is surrounded on
three sides by seas, by oceans, so the boundaries
are quite clear. But of course, on the third,
on the fourth side towards, uh, Asia, uh, the
boundary is anything but clear. So, 2.5 1000 years
ago, we had the Persians trying to cross that
line being fought off by the Greeks. Today since
2022 or 2014. Uh, PERHAPS we have, uh, authoritarian
Russia under Vladimir Putin, again, trying to, you know,
redefine that, um, trying to redefine that line. So,
uh, geographically, there is a contested space, and that's
the kind of fact that we can map on
the ground. And if you chart the line between
those two points, you know, the Battle of Marathon
in 480 BCE and say the siege of Mariupol
in and destruction of Mariupol in 2022 of our
own era, you know, there is a continuous line
of continuous continuous battles, continuous contests over that. That
line. But if it was only lines on a
map in a way, there might not be such
a story to be told, uh, this is where
the history of ideas comes in, because on the
European side of that line, there have always been
people who have In different ways, tried to separate
themselves or to understand their own identity in relation
in opposition to those on the outside. So, Under
those pressures and under enormous internal pressures as well,
because Europeans have spent most of their, uh, 2500
year history fighting against each other. Let's be quite
honest about this, you know, the identity of Europe
itself has been continually contested. Um, AND that too
is part of the story. And one of the
things that, you know, I think comes out of,
I would like, I'd like to think comes out
of my book is that The kind of idea
of Europe, the values that we associate with Europe,
uh, today. Again, I would point out, they have
very ancient roots. But these They only became formulated
in a political way as recently as I would
say the 1970s. Many people say that say the
1940s, but, you know, the, uh, European values of,
you know, human rights, democracy, rule of law, um,
these are really become enshrined in European documents in
the, in the early 19 uh the early 1970s.
And if you look back at a lot of
European history, um, you know, These things are not
very much to the fore, especially democracy. I mean,
Europe, Europe was not democratic, uh, for many more
centuries than it has been, uh, democratic. So when
you take the long view, You know, my argument
is that the, the content of the idea of
Europe has been, uh, you know, as much up
for grabs, open to change and development as the
geographical line that divides Europe from Asia. But just
like that geographical line, equally, I argue, there has
always been one. And that's why there is a
story, you know, a new history if you like,
of Europe to be told.
Yeah, yes, it's interesting because geographically speaking, there are,
for example, countries like Turkey where, OK, is Turkey
a part of Europe, part of Asia, is it
half European, half Asian, and then of course when
it comes to Russia, I, I mean, is just
the western part of Russia, part of, Europe and
then all the rest is part of Asia, is
Russian, European or not, and even I guess we
could extend also the discussion to Eastern Europe because
some, uh, many times people distinguish between Western Europe
and Eastern Europe. I mean, why do they do
that? Is it because they think of Eastern Europe?
As sufficiently distinct from Western Europe. And so if
and if that's the case, then is Eastern Europe
less European when it comes to the core political
identity and the core values associated with Europe, or
what are they doing there when they make that
distinction?
Well, there's a lot in that question. Thank you.
I mean, I'll take the second part of it,
uh, part of it first, because in a way,
it's easier. I mean, Western and Eastern Europe, those
terms, uh, I mean, In a broad kind of
geographical sense, I mean, I think you're based in
Portugal, you can call that Western Europe because, you
know, it's it's further west, um, if you're in,
uh, let's take something fairly uncontroversial, uh, Poland or
Slovakia, uh, you're obviously in, in Eastern Europe, but,
The geopolitical sense in which people have talked about
Western and Eastern Europe was, you know, it was
a real thing, very specifically between 1945 and 1991,
or perhaps 1989 when the Berlin Wall fell or
1991 when the Soviet Union uh was wound up.
Um, IT was a reality created by the Cold
War. Um. And that certainly had it, you know,
it, it had its effect. I mean, I grew
up for the, you know, all my formative years.
I grew up in a world in which Europe
equaled Western Europe. And the Europe, I, you know,
I knew when I was growing up that I
was lucky enough to travel in as a as
an adolescent, um, was invariably Western Europe, you know,
the, the Iron Curtain divided Europe in two. And,
um, I think, you know, I'd be, it's true
that, you know, when, uh, when I was working
on this book, I mean, there were parts of
Europe lying in the former Soviet East, which, um,
you know, I'm the first to admit, I mean,
I have much less direct personal knowledge of and
had to work harder to learn about. But I
mean, it was equally, they're all equally part of
my, uh, part of my project. And of course,
geographically, uh, Greece, which is my specialist area, uh,
has always lain in Eastern Europe, whereas geopolitically, because
of the Cold War divide, it was always thought
of as part of the West. So there, you
know, there, there are sort of odd, uh, you
know, odd sort of, um, consequences of that uh
divide. But I mean, it was an artificial divide.
And as far as I'm concerned, I mean, taking
again, taking the long view, Europe is You know,
is, is the whole of Europe, however, it is
defined at the, uh, at the time. Now, going
back to the first part of your question, beyond
the boundaries of Europe, there are today two nation
states. Uh, Russia, uh, the Russian Federation, and the
Republic of Turkey, as we're now supposed to call
Turkey, um, which lie on the, you know, lie
on the contest always contested eastern borders of Europe,
and the relation of each of those to Europe
is a fascinating story, which, uh, again, you know,
I'd like to deal with more, but I do
discuss it, uh, quite a lot in my, in
my book. And one of the things I actually,
uh, I actually came up with that is a
kind of sophistry, but it helped me tell my
story. WAS Um, the, for, uh, for 2 100
years from 1703 until 1918, the capital of Russia,
of the Russian Empire, was actually in Europe. You
know, Peter the Great invaded Europe, uh, conquered land
from Sweden as it was at that time, and
he built a new capital in Saint Petersburg. So,
the capital of. You know, the, the capital of,
uh, of the Russian Empire was actually in Europe.
And for, for at least for those, for those
years in Russia, the, the Russian Empire, the, the
Russian elite, it was European, uh, you know, one
of the extraordinary cultural things, uh, facts about, uh,
Tsarist Russia was that, you know, educated elite Russians
spoke French among themselves, uh, not Russian. A lot
of the archives of Tsarist Russia are, you know,
preserved in, uh, in French, not, uh, not Russian.
Uh, Tolstoy, it is, uh, you know, uh, the
probably the greatest novel ever written, War and Peace,
really, you know, takes issue with that. But, you
know, a lot of people, they actually speak French,
um, and similarly. Um, WHEN, uh, the Ottoman Empire,
uh, you know, came into Europe, they conquered, uh,
Christian Constantinople, the great sort of imperial city of
eastern, uh, Christian Europe, and, uh, Istanbul, Constantinople was
the capital of the Ottoman Empire until 1923. Um,
AND it was only after that, that, you know,
the, uh, modern modern Turkey is its capital at
Ankara. And, uh, as it happens, I've just come
back from a trip to Istanbul and Ankara. And,
you know, it's fascinating, actually, you know, standing on
the Bosphorus, looking across from Europe to Asia and
from, you know, taking the boat across, just how
narrow that water is. And you've got a city
in Istanbul, which is, you know, it has deep
European roots, but can you call it today a
European city? You know, it's uh exactly on the,
uh, on the edge. And I think the relation
between, uh, the Republic of Turkey and Europe is
a fascinating one. There have been, you know, there
were, for from the 1980s to the 2010s, there
were very serious discussions, possibilities that, uh, Turkey might
join the might join the European Union. And, um,
I mean, I think that that becomes, you know,
it's become vanishingly unlikely, uh, unlikely today as Turkey
under President Erdogan has taken a different, uh, a
different route. But it's, uh, you know, Turkey, like
Russia, um, historically, it's been both inside Europe and
outside. And it's a, there's a changing question of,
you know, identity of self-definition for both those countries.
Again, you know, Russia under Yeltsin in the 1990s
was very much looking towards Europe. It was adopting,
again, European methods of, of government administration. It all
went, uh, it all went terribly wrong, terribly, uh,
terribly quickly. But again, you know, there was world
talk, it was Russia going to join the European
Union. Was Russia going to join NATO, you know,
and in principle, you know, historically, why not? You
know, from a European point of view, surely one
would much rather have one's, uh, large, powerful neighbors
inside the tent or at least speaking the same
kind of cultural diplomatic language, uh, rather than being
opposed. But, you know, Putin's Russia, it seems to
me, has taken the initiative in defining itself as
Stalin's Russia did in opposition to Europe, rather than
in partnership. And I do wonder where President Erdogan's
turkey may be going.
Yeah, I think it's also interesting to look at
how culturally we think about Europe and also the
West. I mean, side by side, because for example,
I'm a football enthusiast and in the European Champions
League, I mean sometimes we get even Israeli teams
there and of course Istanbul, I mean, there are
two big themes there, Fenerbahce and Galatasaray, and it's
not, and it's not like, uh, I'm not sure.
I can, I can never remember exactly which one
of them is on the Asian side of Istanbul,
but it's not like we don't allow that team
to participate in the European Champions League, right? And
then, for example, in the Eurovision Song Contest, again,
we extend. And sort of they invite to participate
to countries that are part of what we usually
think of as Central Asia that were former colonies
of Russia or were part of the former Soviet
Union and and and even to Israel and Australia.
So I mean, culturally at least it seems like.
That even when we attach euro to the name
or European to the Champions League, that what we
consider to be a culturally part of that, I
mean, is not strictly geographical,
right? Um, ABSOLUTELY, and, um, I mean, I confess,
I mean, I'm, I don't, you know, I don't,
I don't, I don't, I'm not, I'm not a
very sporting person, I'm afraid. I don't follow football
and I'm, I'm not worried by the Eurovision Song
Contest either. But I do remember, I mean, I
have, I have read that the Eurovision Song Contest
was originally actually inspired as an idea. Um, YOU
know, is 11 way in which European, the developing,
you know, the European Common Market as it was
at that time, actually attempted to put down cultural
roots. Um, AND, uh, you know, it, it obviously
didn't work very well because I don't think people
think of it in that way. And as you
say, it's geographical reach has, uh, you know, it's
almost as, as bizarre as, you know, that of,
of the West, you know, we talk about the
West and it includes Taiwan and Japan and Australia.
Um, BUT it doesn't include South America or West
Africa. Um, YOU know, the act of cultural and
geopolitical ideas, they have a life of their own.
And, um, they can be rather bizarre. So, I
mean, I think the story of Eurovision is an
example of how an attempt to consolidate a European
sense of sort of solidarity definition, um, actually, you
know, failed very quickly. Um. And on the other
hand, football, which as I say, I don't follow
closely, but for what I do follow, I mean,
I'm quite impressed that, you know, UEFA as an
institution does seem to work. And you know, I
sort of quite impressed that UEFA has stood up
against uh FIFA and Infantino, and uh there is
a sense, there is a sense of, um, in
a community that, you know, I'm not myself close
to, but I can see there is a sporting
community that is European, that does seem to have
an identity of its own. And, um, you know,
one thing that does impress me and sports commentators
in Britain, they're always able to pronounce the names
of foreign players. You know, of European managers and
players and so on. Whereas, you know, Brits famously
can never pronounce foreign names. They never get the
names of politicians right. But, uh, but football players,
football players, they do. Um. Uh, YOU know, who
in Britain knows how to how to pronounce Swedish
names, but, you know, the former Svenjon Eriksson, you
know, the jon bit, you couldn't, you're working out
from the spelling, but everybody had it right, and
they're, I think, in a kind of serious, there's
a serious side to this that in those kinds
of ways. You know, Europeans do share something. And
um the the more more strength to that. Again,
as you say, I mean, UEFA like the Eurovision
Song Contest has kind of porous boundaries. And um
certainly, you know, there's a there's a whole, well,
there's a whole other debate about uh about Israel
and indeed the very status of Israel is um.
It it is part of that, it's part of
that discussion because, you know, many people, or historians
have described Israel as a European implant or transplant
in the geographical space of the Middle East. And
of course, this is profoundly and rather terribly contested
in, uh, in our own times. Um, SO, you
know, how do Israelis, uh, identify today in relation
to Europe, which for many of them is their
ancestral country. Um, HOW do, you know, how do
people in the continent of Europe, uh, view, you
know, the middle, that part of the Middle East.
Um, SO, which again, it illustrates just how, uh,
unstable these ideas, these ideas of these identities, uh,
are. And I'm not, you know, I don't think
there's anything wrong with that. I think it's the
nature of identity to continue to develop.
Yes, but when it comes to the European identity,
how strong is it really among people who nowadays
live in what we call Europe? I mean, because
of course nowadays we have the question of we
living in nation states which was not quite the
Same, uh, for, I, I, I guess most of
history, even European history, but the, uh, I mean,
is it really that people, I don't know, I'm
Portuguese, is it really that people who live in
Portugal or in Spain or France or Bulgaria, uh,
really have a strong association. WITH the European identity,
or is it weaker than, for example, being Bulgarian
or French or German, and sometimes I mean people
might even not quite like to be associated with
a broader European identity.
Well, I mean, the short answer is, I wish,
I wish I knew, and I don't know quite
how one would know. I mean, you know, at
the level of statistics, I mean, there is a
lot of polling on this, the Euro poll and
various, you know, attitudes to the European Union. But
I think to the extent to which people feel
European or not, um, it's, it goes deeper than
that and it's subtler than that. So I don't
know quite how you would measure it. Um. And
so it's bound, I think, to be a little
bit subjective. I mean, it does impress me. I
mean, parts of Europe that I know, um, you
know, I'm always, I've always, you know, noticed the,
uh, the European flag when it's being, you know,
it's being flown on public buildings. And, um, it's
all, you know, every time I see it, I'm
also struck by the fact that during the half
century that my own country was part of that
union. Um, I almost never saw that flag in
Britain. Um. Uh, AND of course, there is, you
know, there's a whole, the whole issue of Brexit,
um, which I try not to talk about in
my book, but, you know, it is part of,
uh, part of the history of, uh, of, of,
uh, of these islands. And, um, You know, 1010
years ago, when a narrow minority of Britons voted
to leave the European Union, there was a lot
of discourse about Europe or somewhere else. It was
us and them. Europe was the other side. But
since the full scale invasion of Ukraine, some of
the same public figures who spoke very vigorously against
Europe and saw us as being non-European. Now talk
equally vigorously about the defense of Europe, and they're
very keen to promote, uh, Britain's role in the
communal defense of Europe. And this is what, you
know, I said earlier that sometimes I wonder whether
the people who talk about Europe as an idea
actually know themselves, uh, what they mean by it.
Because there seems to be, it seems to me
there's a huge shift, uh, a huge shift there,
um. And I think it's a, you know, it's
a matter of perspective of proportion. I mean, one
thing, you know, I take the, the example, I,
I would say, you know, in Britain, I'm Scottish,
in, uh, you know, in, uh, in say, Lithuania,
I'm British. In, uh, then in Greece, I, I,
you know, I spent a lot of time in
Greece. I was given, uh, honorary citizenship. So, you
know, I could also feel, uh, feel Greek. And
if I go to Australia, I'm European. And it
doesn't, it doesn't worry me to have those several
layers of identity. Oh, and I mean, as Scottish,
I come from Edinburgh, not Glasgow. And at a
certain, and at a certain level, that really matters.
You know, you're talking about football, Celtic and Rangers,
um. You know, those two cities are very close
together, but I, in terms of identity, they're poles
apart. Um, SO, you know, identity, it seems to
me as the sort of hierarchy of identities. And
I don't see why they should be in conflict.
It's a question of, you know, at the particular
moment under particular pressures, which identity comes to the
fore. And I, I do wonder whether actually the,
uh, Putin's attack on Ukraine isn't actually helping to,
uh, You know, to bring Europeans together that, again,
at a certain level, um, people who primarily think
of themselves as Bulgarian or Greek or Portuguese or
British, um, are also perhaps talking more about the
common European identity, because they see that as under
threat. And, you know, sometimes it's, you know, identity
is In part, it's about defining oneself in relation
to other things. So, the, you know, the military
attack from the east is one thing that I
think has probably strengthened the European sense of identity.
And then now the last, the last couple of
years coming from across the Atlantic, um, you know,
we get the, uh, we get the, the, the
tirades and tantrums from a very, uh, unstable and
unpredictable US president. Um, WHICH again, you know, who,
who basically seems to hate Europe or at least
hates the idea of, uh, uh, of Europe as
most Europeans understand it. Um, SO, you know, again,
that kind of, uh, that kind of very negative,
very aggressive rhetoric. Um, I'm sure I'm not the
only person who lives in Europe who thinks, well,
damn it, you know, I'm, uh, uh, you know,
I want to stand up against that as a
European. So I think there, you know, there is
potential. It's there, but how strong it is at
the moment and how much, you know, how it
relates to the, uh, primary national identity, which still
seems to dominate, um, you know, I think it's
an open question.
Yeah, I think, I think it's quite flexible. I
think it's quite flexible because even here in the
Iberian Peninsula, I'm in Portugal and Spain, there are
times where we talk about the Spanish people as
being our Iberian brothers, but then there are other
times where there's, there seems to be a big
rivalry. So for example, if our national teams are
playing against each other, of course. WE hate the
Spanish bastards, but when, for example, but if, for
example, Spain plays Argentina in the World Cup final,
then we are suddenly Iberian brothers because we have
to be against Lionel Messi, who is the rival
of Cristiano Ronaldo, you know, so there's all of
those dynamics playing on there. And also I remember
when the late Jose Saramagu, the 1998. Nobel Prize
in Literature, who was Portuguese. I mean, he had
this idea that Portugal and Spain should be unified
because of the Iberian identity, but I mean, Portuguese
people didn't want to have anything to do with
that, and he was even ostracized for a very
long time in our own country. So, you know,
it seems that there's sort of a A dynamic
process in terms of how we think about our
own identity that perhaps can become broader or or
more limited depending on what we're talking about, I
guess.
I think that's that chimes very much with what
you know what I was saying. I think you
know you think of again, you know, another layer
is the Iberian identity or You know, again, there
could be, you know, sort of, um, uh, the,
you know, another famous writer, Milan Kundera, you know,
wrote very influentially about a Central European identity, which
he felt had been, you know, eroded, been, been,
well, sort of, uh, attacked by the, um, by,
by, by Soviet domination in, uh, in eastern Central
and Eastern Europe. So that, you know, there, there,
there are, um, there are regional identities as well
as national. But, I mean, I suppose one thing
I, you know, today, I think uncontroversially, uh, for
most people, it is the national identity that, uh,
is predominant. And there are some arguments about, you
know, exactly where you define that. So, you know,
we have separatism in Catalonia, in Scotland, um, you
know, and possibly in other parts of, uh, in
other parts of Europe. Um. But, um, the, that,
you know, that that whole, the idea of the
nation as something that primarily defines people and one
nation actually against another. Um, THAT idea is actually
no older than the late 18th century. And it
really came to dominate Europe as recently as the
19th century. Many of the nation states of Europe
were actually created as recently as 1919 in the
wake of the First World War. And some of
those have broken up again, Yugoslavia, Czechoslovakia, for example.
Um, SO, the, you know, we sometimes, I think,
you know, in adhering to the nation state and
clinging to the idea of the nation state, I
think, you know, we often fail to realize that
this is only one way for people to organize
themselves to define their identity. And Again, I think
looking at the broader history of Europe and trying
to, as I do in my book, put Europe
as a whole in the primary focus, it, I
would like to think of it as a kind
of counterbalance to that. I mean, not to weaken
or not to challenge national identity, but simply to
complement it. But as well as being Portuguese, Scottish,
Greek, etc. YOU know, we are all also European.
And that matters because as Europeans, We share a
history that goes back for 2.5 1000 years. Whereas,
you know, the history of England or Britain or
Scotland, um, goes back it's a number of hundreds
of years. And I know Portugal is is one
of the oldest states in uh in Europe going
back to, I think the 14th century, certainly the
15th, certainly powerful in the 15th century. Um, BUT,
uh, you know, even then, you know, Portugal or
England was an independent identity, because of the, uh,
you know, it was a monarchy. It was the
monarch who defined the identity rather than the people.
And, you know, the, the nat, the, the sort
of national solidarity is something that came, uh, that
came was built on that much, uh, much later.
So it's, you know, that's one way of organizing
societies is not the only one. And we have
a much, you know, an older and broader one
that I would call European.
Yeah, so, uh, going back in history a little
bit, uh, what would you say was the impact,
if any, of the Roman Empire on the formation
of a European identity?
Fundamental I think you can't, you can't really think
of Europe post the Roman Empire in any other
way than through the perspective of that empire. The
Romans, uh, by pretty violent means, it must be
said. Uh, UNIFIED by far the largest part of
the European continent as we now think of it,
that has ever been politically unified, as well as
extending what I think of as sort of bulwarks
of defenses in the Middle East and in North,
uh, in North. South Africa. So the, the Roman
Empire was in geopolitical, uh, terms. I'm not, not,
I'm not speaking ethically here. It was in geopolitical
terms. It was much the most successful European sort
of political experiment that there's, uh, there's ever been.
And Say what you like about Rome and many
people have. Um, THE example of that unified continent
is something that Europeans in successive generations and successive
centuries have looked back to with different kinds of
nostalgia. So, every attempt really to bring Europe together
in one way or another has looked back to
the example of the Roman Emperor. I mean, Charlemagne
famously being crowned in Rome as an emperor of
of the Romans. Of course, he couldn't bring back
the Roman Empire Empire, but it was very much
the. For what he was doing. Similarly, the rather,
the rather vaguer, more inchoate, uh, but in, but
very long lasting, Holy Roman Empire, which lasted for
1000 years for the Middle Ages until 181806, um.
And I mean, again, the, you know, the French
Revolution, um, it was full of uh invocations of
the ancient Roman Republic. Napoleon, when he became an
emperor, modeled himself exactly on the emperors of ancient
Rome. And the Napoleonic Empire, the Napoleonic attempt to
unify Europe by conquest was, you know, quite overtly
in much of its symbolism and rhetoric, uh, an
attempt to revise an extended version of the, uh,
of the Roman Empire. And the European Union and
its institutions, again, I think, you know, you could
detect a lot of nostalgia for Rome. Uh, FOR
Rome in that, uh, obviously not the institutions of
empire, but the institutions of the republic. Um, YOU
know, going back to, I think the 1950s, there's
a, you know, the, uh, European, the European institutions
offer a Charlemagne prize, um, you know, in the
name of the emperor, who was again, the kind
of, you know, sort of neo, uh, Roman, uh,
emperor. Um, AND, you know, I think also the
architecture of modern Europe. And indeed that uh European
colonists uh took around the world, you know, it's
sort of, um, you know, neoclassical architecture. It's imitating
the buildings of ancient, uh, ancient Rome and ancient,
ancient Greece. You know, look at the American capital,
built on based on the Roman building of the
American Supreme Court based on an ancient Greek temple.
Um, SO, it's, um, it's something that, you know,
it runs through, it's kind of in the cultural
DNA of medieval and, uh, modern and modern Europe.
Do you think that, uh, with the fall of
the Western Roman Empire, and er then with the,
er rise of the er Byzantine Empire, er, that,
There, I mean that division between the West, the
Western and the Eastern Roman Empire, and for example,
even religiously, the divide between Catholicism in Europe and
Orthodox Christianity in the East. Or the Middle East,
do you think that that historically has played any
role at all in how we think about Europe
and the East or the West and the East
or what we think is part of Europe and
what is not part of Europe?
It's an interesting question that, and I mean, I
think there's a lot of confusion uh around that.
Um, I mean, I was very struck that, you
know, a famous book, um, by the late Samuel
Huntington called The Clash of Civilizations published in the
mid 1990s, um, really defined civilization in sort of
ethno-religious terms. And, um, He draws a line between
Western Catholicism and its Protestant offshoots, um, on the
one hand, and Orthodox Eastern Europe and Russia on
the other. Um. And You know, I mean, I,
I always had great trouble with that. And, um,
you know, already, already, um, you know, uh, 30
years later, and that idea seems very, seems very
outdated that Christianity, whether Orthodox or or or Catholic
or Protestant, um, It's very much, you know, it's
very much, it's history is very much grounded in
the history of Europe. And you know, it's spread
to other countries, including, uh, including Russia. But the
division between the Catholic and Orthodox Church is, is
a, to my mind, it's a division within Europe,
within what the, uh, you know, what Catholic medieval
Europe called the Res Publica Christiana, the Christian, uh,
republic or Commonwealth is usually trans uh translated, um.
But I do think, you know, the perhaps, you
know, the most, the one of the defining characteristics
and to my mind, uh, the, the great tragedy
of medieval Europe was the destruction of the city
of Constantinople in 1204 by the Fourth Crusade. That
actually, Christianity, at the very point when controversially, of
course, it was taking up arms against Islam in
the east. Actually, Western powers, um, took up arms
against the greatest Christian city in Europe, which is
Constantinople. And because they, you know, they captured it,
they sacked it, they looted it, uh, they dismantled
the uh the Byzantine Empire. They also unwittingly destroyed
the most powerful bulwark that Europe had in the
southeast, southeast corner against the advance of Islam. Into
Europe. So the long term consequence of the 1204
destruction of Orthodox Constantinople was the advance a few
centuries later of the Ottoman Turks, um, who of
course took Constantinople, uh definitively, finally in 1453. And
by that time, they'd already conquered much of Europe
in the eastern Mediterranean, um, at its, at its
furthest extent, the Ottoman advance, uh, it twice threatened,
uh, Vienna in 1529 and 1683. It, um, the
Ottoman navy was stopped from from entering Europe through
the Mediterranean. Um, IN 1571 at the Battle of,
uh, Lepanto. But, you know, again, these things were,
you know, pretty hard fought and pretty, uh, pretty
uncertain. So that, I mean, if you like, the
division in Eastern and Western Christianity, Catholicism and Orthodoxy,
it was a classic example of how Europeans fighting
among themselves. Uh, AND intra-European disputes actually laid, you
know, Europeans open to, uh, conquest by, by, by,
uh, by others.
Yeah, and conquest by others, which includes of course
the Islamic expansion into Western Europe. I mean, what
kind of impact, if any, do you think that
Islamic expansion might have had in the development of
the European identity?
Um, I think it was, again, I mean, I
think it was probably pretty fundamental because, um, You
know, suddenly in the 7th century, when Islam began
to, you know, burst upon the world, um, the
um Uh, when Islam began to burst burst upon
the world, I mean, this, this became a new
threat to the already disintegrating, uh, Roman Empire. And
from that time on, very quickly, you know, Europe
and Europeans, the descendants, uh, cultural descendants, that is
of Of Romans defined themselves by their Christian identity
and their opposition to Islam. Now, I mean, one
consequence of defining Europe in the way I do
in my book, and it may be that, you
know, readers, you, you and readers in Portugal, um,
uh, are, are, you know, uh, may not agree
with this, is that, um, actually, the, you know,
the Muslim conquest of most of Iberia, actually, you
know, detaches your part of the world from Europe
for several centuries. Now, of course, the, you know,
as we now know, I mean, the Muslim heritage,
the Muslim, uh, element in the history of both
Spain and Portugal is a very important part of
both regional and national, uh, history, and it deserves
to be, you know, we all acknowledge that, you
know, the Islamic culture of, you know, certainly places
like, um, you know, Cordoba and Granada, um, was,
uh, you know, probably at a higher level than
existed in Christian Europe, uh, at the time. But
in terms of defining Europe as, as, um, you
know, as Christianity, as a society, uh, ruled by
Christian, by, by Christian rulers, um, you know, I'm
afraid Muslim Muslim, you know, Al Andalus, Muslim Iberia
stands outside that, and then the The reconquest, it
becomes the process whereby, uh, Europe, just as it's
being pressed from the east, um, uh, reconquers, you
know, moves west to, to recapture first Portugal, and
then all of, uh, and then all of, uh,
Spain. Um, BUT whether in Iberia, or in the
Crusades or in uh Southeastern Europe, um, that, you
know, that conflict with Islam is, um, again, it
probably it is probably You know, as much as
any, it's a defining characteristic of, um, European identity.
And, you know, right through medieval Europe, my medieval
literature, medieval theology, um, you know, so much of
the rhetoric seems to be driven by actual fear
of Islam. Um, YOU know, almost an inferiority complex,
uh, yeah, vis a vis Islam, which in turn
helps to define the Christian concept, identity of Europe,
which I think lasts for more than 1000 years.
When it comes to European colonization of the Americas
and then of course also eventually Africa, parts of
Southeast Asia and Oceania, I mean, do you think
that uh that colonization from the 16th century onwards
influenced how we think about Europe and Europeans?
Absolutely. I mean, I think the European encounter with
peoples on other continents who had who had no
previous experience of Europeans at all. The, um, you
know, these were totally people who were totally alien,
um, in, you know, in every cultural sense. They'd
obviously never heard of, uh, Of, uh, of Christianity,
of Jesus Christ or of God or, you know,
people who've been brought up to believe that mankind
was created in the Garden of Eden, and that
all human beings alive today are part of a
universal plan devised by the Christian God. Um, YOU
know, it was an extraordinary shock to them. And,
um, you know, we, we often think of this
as being Uh, a sort of national story. And
of course, you know, Portugal takes the lead in
this. It was the 15th century where, uh, Portuguese
explorers, um, really, you know, uh, brought European ways,
brought Europeans into contact with the very different civilizations
of Africa, India, China, and Japan. Um, BUT probably
the greatest cultural shock was the, uh, you know,
was the discovery of the, uh, of, of the
Americas. And again, I mean, the point that I
would emphasize, and that again, I think it's worth
studying more than I was able to do in
my book. I just made a start, is that
this goes beyond the actual, you know, achievements of
Portugue of Portuguese explorers, Portuguese captains of Columbus, who,
you know, well, it wasn't even Spanish, you know,
we think of these in national terms because the
stories were told that way. But actually, all Europeans
were involved, um. You know, Columbus from Genoa, there
were people from Britain. Um, A lot of the,
uh, you know, the, uh, the, the money for
these exploration for these explorations was raised, uh, in
the Holy Roman Empire in southern German banks. So,
you know, I think this was actually, it was
Europe that was encountering other civilizations. And that it
was similarly the whole of Europe that really experienced
a cultural, a culture shock that he couldn't quite
cope with. And I, I can't believe this is
my own original idea, but it certainly struck me
very strongly, and I brought it out in my
book. But surely that cultural encounter must be one
of the causes underlying the deep split in Europe
that we know of as the Protestant Protestant Reformation.
Because it began at exactly the same time in
the in the 151520s, you know, suddenly the whole
Catholic or indeed Orthodox Christian worldview was challenged. It
was shattered. And Europeans themselves in response to that
shock, uh, you know, began to, I mean, Europe
itself broke. Apart, the, the chapter of my book
that discusses both these things. Um, YOU know, I,
I, I found this title, which I think sums
up, I hope sums that up really rather well.
It's called it, you know, Breaking Out, that's the
Americas, and breaking up. That's the Protestant Reformation. I
link these two things integrally.
Uh, BUT of course, uh, through colonization, Europeans came
across other what we now call civilizations in America,
Africa, and so on. But back then, Um, how
did Europeans think about the concept of civilization, because
I don't think that back then in the 16th,
17th century, Europeans would have associated the concept of
civilization to whatever kinds of societies or political organizations
that they encountered throughout the Americas, for example, right?
Uh, INDEED, and in the 16th century, the word
civilization had not yet been coined. I mean, it's
a, it's a, it's a French word. It was
first used during the 1750s, um, during the characteristically
during the Enlightenment. So, you know, that's one way
of defining human society that, you know, belongs to
the Enlightenment, not to that earlier period. Um, THERE
were two concepts that the Europeans at that time,
uh, had been brought up with. One was, obviously,
the defining one was Christianity. And by definition, all
these, all these people they encountered were, you know,
they were what they called heathens, they were pagans.
Um, SO they had to be, you know, they
had to be converted. Um, AND because they didn't,
you know, they didn't have the benefit of the,
uh, divine revelation that inherently made them inferior. In
European eyes at the time. The other idea which
was, um, had been revived at that uh just
recently before that, and I think underlies much of
the Christian Middle Ages as well, is what the
ancient Romans called humanitas, which is a It's a,
it's a term that, you know, broadly and roughly
corresponds to our own civilization. It means things like
living, you know, living in, in cities sort of
urban frameworks, laws, um, you know, politeness, um, you
know, ways of having ways of, you know, um,
basically urban, you know, urban. Urban life. And some
of, you know, some of that they may have
seen in the peoples that they encountered. On the
other hand, you know, the, um, certainly in English,
the standard term, I think, you know, use of
non-European peoples was savages. You know, they were, um,
you know, just as the ancient Greeks talked about
the barbarian Persians, the people who lived in other
continents, they were, you know, they were savage. They
didn't have the benefit of either Christianity, or the
kind of, uh, kind of laws and, you know,
laws and social structures that Europeans were used to.
Um, THOUGH they never said that about the Chinese
or the Japanese or the Or I think, oh,
the surely the Indians, I mean, you know, these
were, um, the people the Portuguese were first to
encounter actually were more advanced civilizations than Europeans. Whereas,
you know, the, the Central American civilizations that the
uh the Spanish first encountered, um, the, you know,
the, the, I mean, even today, I mean, they,
they do look pretty grim, I think in the
way, you know, the, uh, particularly the Aztecs with
their emphasis on, uh, on human sacrifice, um. Though,
I mean, somebody, I do, I'm not sure it
was, somebody made the point that, you know, when,
uh, when Cortez went to Mexico and you know,
found it was horrified at the, you know, the
human sacrifice, and actually the Spanish also practiced human
sacrifice in the outer dafe, you know, they burned
people at the stake, which is, you know, just
as, just as horrific. So it's not to say
Europeans were any better, in other words, it's a
matter of perspective,
right? Uh, BUT after the World Wars in the
20th century and with the progressive dissolution of the
what are now the former European colonial empires, uh,
do you think that European identity, it changed in
a significant way?
Uh, Well, I mean, well, actually, well, I, it's
not quite an answer to your question, but I
mean, one thing that does strike me, and again,
I think is worth discussing, you know, is worth,
I'd like to write more about this, is the
way decolonization, the abolition of all these, all these
European empires has actually gone hand in hand with
the spread of Systems and ideas and technologies that
ultimately had their origin in Europe, actually right around
the world. And You know, almost, you know, almost
every country in the world uses terms like republic
and peoples and and democracy, um, you know, regardless
of whether they are at all democratic, um, I'm
very struck that, you know, China with its ancient
imperial history that's quite different to. European history and
in many ways used to be superior to it,
you know, is ruled by, uh, ruled by the
Chinese Communist Party. And, you know, this is, at
least in name, this is a system of government
that goes back to a German intellectual writing in
London in the 19th century. And, um, you know,
in the when they have their, their, their meetings,
all these delegates in China, they're all wearing European
suits. And It's really strikes me, you know, the,
the, the tailoring, the, you know, the garment, you
know, why do they do this? You know, it,
it's they, they're dressed as Europeans, but they dress
with a uniformity that I think would be unimaginable
anywhere in Europe. Um, YOU know, and, and similarly,
you know, the world's media, um, they, um, you
know, they, they talk in the same kinds of
ways. People dress in the same kind of way.
You have symphony orchestras, uh, you have no, you
know, literature, novels, films. These are all things that
began in, in Europe. They've gone, they've gone global,
um. And that I think is probably as much
the effect of European soft power, which went hand
in hand with uh decolonization, as of the more
aggressive expansionism of earlier, uh of earlier centuries. How
is Europe in itself been affected by this? Um,
IN a way, in a way, I think perhaps
it's too early to, uh, it's too early to
say. I mean, 11 consequence of that decolonization, of
course, has been, you know, as I think I
said in the book, um, You know, in early
centuries, Europe went out to the rest of the
world. Since the particularly Second World War, the rest
of the world has come to Europe too. And
in recent, uh, in the last decade, this has,
of course, produced what we now regard as a
crisis of inward migration of in the non-European, uh,
non-white, non-Christian, uh, people. And You know, that seems
to, you know, for some Europeans, that seems to
create a real problem. Um, TO my mind, you
know, these are people coming, you know, peacefully in
in dispersed groups. They're not, uh, they're not led
by military force. They don't bring it, they don't,
uh, they don't come as a, uh, as a
threat. They're not trying to take over our, uh,
our European society. They're simply becoming, uh, becoming part
of it. Um, SO, you know, it seems to
me that the, the threat from, uh, from of
Russian, uh, state power is a far greater threat
than that of inward migration. And indeed, the, the,
the threat of, um, so far only rhetorical, uh,
from the United States again, you know, threatens, uh,
I think it's a kind of more existential threat
to Europe than inward inward migration. Um. History tells
us that people who have migrated into Europe, which
includes actually all of us at one point, some
time or other, uh, you know, have become European
in the sense that living here, they define themselves
as Europeans. And it is those are the people
who have, um, you know, who have established a
European identity for the same reason. You know, if
you look at the long history of Europe from,
you know, from prehistory to the present day. There
cannot be any such thing as any kind of
racial identity of Europe because everybody is coming to
Europe and you know, we've all mixed and mingled
and these are the people who became Europeans. So,
the, uh, you know, the kind of the American
alt-right inspired idea of a European pure race, as
something that, you know, Hitler and the Nazis promoted
in the 1930s is sim is simply, you know,
it's, it's simply nonsensical. It's indefensible. Um. Anybody can
become European, just as once upon a time, anyone
could become Greek or Roman.
And of course we also have the European Union.
Do you think that uh after the creation of
the European Union and as progressively more states became
part of it, That being being in or out
of the European Union has an impact or influences
in any way how people develop their European identity.
So I live in Portugal, we're still part of
the European Union. The United Kingdom until 2016 was
also part of the European Union, but then, Since
then, it left, but I mean, do you think
that being part of the European Union or not
influences in any way how people understand their own
European identity?
I don't know. And in a way that that
depends on, you know, how one sees the effectiveness,
effectiveness of European institutions. Um, I would like, you
know, I would like to think it does. I
was obviously chagrined by, uh, by Brexit. Um, I
persist in regarding it as a temporary aberration. And,
you know, I think the history of the last
10 years, certainly the last 5 years since Britain
formally left the European Union shows. Just how ineffectual
even such a large, a large and, you know,
economically, sometimes military power as Britain has been, you
know, how actually ineffectual, uh, post-Brexit Britain, uh, necessarily
is on the, on the world, uh, on the
world stage. Um, BUT, you know, I also see,
um, Uh, signs that, you know, there are forms
of cooperation among you, uh, in Europe and among
Europeans, which actually transcend the formal boundaries of the
European Union. So, um, Uh, so, you know, with
the, these various talk, you know, they, they talk
about European defense, um, um, and then, you know,
Norway and Switzerland are also not formally part of
the European Union. But these countries have various, you
know, uh, have, have different relations to the European
Union. I mean, I think, I just think the
initiative is always going to come from the European
center. And it seems to be a shame from
the British point of view that we remain on
the periphery rather than at the center as we,
uh, as we were. Mhm
So we've already touched a little bit on this
earlier, but when it comes to the current war
in Ukraine, uh, how does, um, the way we
think about our European identity manifest in regards to
how we look at Ukraine and how we look
at Russia?
Well, I mean, again, OK, I mean, one thing
that, I don't know quite what, I don't know
what the attitudes are in Portugal, but I mean,
I'm quite interested by what I've read about the
current Spanish government and the, you know, the line
that is taken in, you know. Um, uh, Prime
Minister Sanchez is, um, you know, resisting increasing, uh,
uh, defense spending, and, um, you know, it seems
to be rather relaxed about the Ukrainian war on
fairly, you know, manifestly on the grounds that it's
a long way away from the Iberian Peninsula. But,
um, you know, with that, perhaps, uh, one exception,
um, it's, I mean, I have the sense that,
you know, you all Europeans are. Waking up to
the, again, you know, the, the common interest. Um,
AND this case goes back to what I was
saying earlier about, you know, about Britain that, you
know, in Britain is a very, you know, British
governments, um, and we've had several, uh, since Brexit.
Uh, British governments of whatever political stripe, um, have
been in the, you know, in the vanguard of
defending Ukraine. Um, AND the rhetoric of doing so
is always in the name of Europe, not of
course, a united Europe, because Brits don't seem to
believe in that. But The fact that you can
see, you know, European, a threat to Europe is
perceived, even though they don't quite spell this out,
a threat to Europe is perceived as a threat,
even here in Britain. Therefore, like it or not,
I think Brits are aware that they are part
of something bigger than themselves. And I think that
goes uh throughout Europe. Understandably, people are much more
nervous in, uh, say, in say, Poland or the
Baltic states than they are in uh in in
France or or Spain. But, you know, it's a,
it's a matter of degree. I mean, I think
all European states are, are nervous to, you know,
they see them, they see the threat in the
same. In the, in the same way,
since we're now in a context where we through
the news and other things, we are exposed to
this potential immediate threat in the case of Russia,
um, do you think that that makes our European
identity more salient?
Um, I mean, there are clear signs that it,
uh, it, it is, I mean, possibly in varying
degrees, depending how close one is geographically to the
Russian threat. So I think it's, you know, it's
visibly more of an issue in countries like Poland
or the Baltics than it is. Uh, IN Iberia,
but, um, clearly, you know, there is a, a
common perception that this is a, a threat to,
uh, to all. What does disturb me is how,
you know, there are potential, uh, quite visible counter
pressures, um. Uh, THERE are far right political parties
which are gaining salience in many parts of Europe,
which, uh, bizarrely given the history, um, seem in
some cases also to be actively pro-Russian, um, the
Alternativa F Deutschland. The alternative for Germany. I mean,
it seems to be particularly, um, you know, bizarre,
extraordinary in that, in that, uh, context. But the
same thing is visible in, in Slovakia, where the,
um, the, the, the president, uh, is, um, is
again, visibly pro, uh, pro-Russian. And what, what, you
know, what this looks like to me is, these
are countries that They were, we, we think of
it as liberated from Russian control in 1989, but
actually, has integration with Europe failed to the point
that they actually are nostalgic for Russian rule, that
they actually want to go back to that. And
I mean, uh, I, I'm even more puzzled in
the case of Poland, where there is a visceral
fear of Russians, which is grounded very, very solidly
in almost 200 years of history. And yet, while
the current Polish government has rowed back from the
sort of far right position of the previous one.
The Poles have also elected a president who, while
not pro-Russian, does seem to be uh anti-European. And
if you're anti-European in the in Central or Eastern
European, you know, which way you're going to go?
Um, I'd have thought that the, you know, the,
the fear or the possibility that uh Russia could
exploit those internal European divisions and, um, Actually regain
the kind of foothold in Europe that Soviet Russia
had during the Cold War. I think that is
a very real fear for all Europeans. Um, AND
again, you know, I think, you know, worrying about
migrants crossing the Mediterranean or the English Channel, uh,
you know, um, defenseless people, you know, I think
it's just, you know, it's just, uh, it's just
bizarre, you know, the, these threats cannot be compared.
Yeah. No, uh, actually I was going to ask
you about immigrants because, I mean, is it the
case that um across European history, um, Things like,
for example, skin color or other aspects of people's
physiognomy or their, of course, national identity was not
much of a thing until the development of modern
nation states, but things like ethnicity, for example, really
play a big role when it comes to People
looking at someone living in Europe and considering them
to be foreign or not, or do you think
that the more recent political developments in terms of,
for example, the far right across different European countries
framing immigration as an invasion of Europe. Associate associating
it to, for example, African people, people from the
Middle East, people from cultural backgrounds that are sufficiently
different from what we tend to associate with European
culture and different ethnic identities has made that more
salient.
Well, I mean, I mean, to my mind. The
differences among human people's populations are cultural, not. Uh,
ETHNIC or, you know, it's not, it's not biology
that really that makes people that that makes people
different. I mean, biologically we are all, we're all
one species and things like skin color, shape of
eyes or whatever, you know, color of hair. These
are, you know, these are, these are pretty superficial
differences among people. But of course, you know, people
have always, have always divided, you know, they've always
divided into groups, they see people as different in
one way or another, and. There obviously are, you
know, deep, well, as I said earlier, you know,
when Europeans first went to the Americas, there were
total cultural differences between them. They were, they had
literally nothing in common. Um. So the, you know,
the peoples they encountered were as different as you
could possibly be. And, you know, what we call
ethnic or racial differences, they, you know, they, they
must have existed on the other side as well.
So, you know, if, if you live, you know,
if you lived in North America, say, In the
17th or 18th century, you know, your lands are
being taken by people with white skins and dressed
in particular ways, practicing a particular religion. Um, YOU
know, in fact, in North America, it's a free
for all. I mean, almost every European nation has
a, uh, you know, has a hand in trying
to conquer bits of North America. Um. At various
times, and I'm sure the, you know, the native
population couldn't tell the difference and certainly, you know,
why should they care? They're all just Europeans. So,
there are these kind of, you know, to begin
with, you know, um, the cultural differences, which are
absolute because people live on different continents without contact.
But, As soon as communication opens up between them,
you know, people are communicating, they're traveling, they're intermarrying,
they're, you know, these, these differences begin to begin
to be ironed out. And, um, you know, and
and people move. So, that's, you know, globalization, if
you like, begins in the 15th, 16th century, uh,
I suppose. And it's a, you know, it's a
probably, it's a probably unstoppable, uh, unstoppable process. Um.
And, you know, would we be better if actually
all these divisions were reinstated that people couldn't travel
from one continent to another, um, you know, you
know, imagine the sort of far right program of
what they call re-migration. Suppose all the dark skinned
people or the Muslims were actually forced out of
Europe. I mean, it's, it's, it's unimaginable. It's impractical.
But I mean, just imagine, you know, I mean,
how could you imagine such a thing? What would
you be left with? Um. You know, would it,
would it make sense? And the point isn't, isn't
the cul the color of people's skin, people's skins,
or in today's, I think, broadly more secular world,
the religion, I mean, religion could become more of
a factor, and that would make a difference. But
in, in, as I say, in today's sort of
broadly secular, broadly global world, I mean, people coming
into Europe who are, you know, are they're African
heritage, they may be Muslim, they may be of
other religions or no religion, um. I mean, the
broad position, as I would understand it is they
want to come to Europe. So long as they
actually want to become European, in a broad sense,
then, you know, why should they not also be
welcome? Um, YOU know, I think the fear is
of people who enter Europe who don't wish to
become European and want to impose something else on
those who are already here. And there, as I
said before, you know, it seems to be the,
the real threat is the people who outside Europe,
who actually have the power to do that, which
is, you know, the great powers, Russia. Uh, Russia,
America, you know, I'm kind of looking to China
because China is a long way away. And, uh,
you know, uh, we talk about threats from China,
but, you know, it is a, it is much
further away from us than either Russia or, uh,
or America.
So I have one last question then. We've already
touched a little bit on it, but I would
like to get a little bit deeper into it.
So, uh, of course, your book is about Europe
and the European identity, but We, uh, when we
talk about the West, we tend to, I mean,
our understanding of the West tends to be, to
be very Eurocentric, and then of course we tend
to, uh, associate it with the, uh, Greco-Roman, with
the basis of a Greco-Roman culture and the Judeo-Christian
culture. I mean, but uh, do you think that
the way we understand the West. I is the
same way we understand Europe and the European identity,
or, uh, if not, what's the distinction there?
Well, I think the West, in inverted commas, has
had its day. I think there actually is no
such thing. It was constructed in the wake of
the Second World War. It was a kind of
vehicle for American hegemony, and it no longer exists.
Um One of the things that I feel I've
learned from studying the history of Europe, and as
I said earlier, you know, I'd like to study
more is the, you know, the actual impact on
the rest of the world that we loosely term
Western. It's not Western at all. It is European.
And I would actually like to, you know, look
at the impact of Europe on the rest of
the world. Um, DECOUPLING Europe from this broader, uh,
um, idea of, of the West. Um, YOU know,
the United States, uh, I mean, became a superpower
really quite, really quite recently. Um, AND it is
itself, you know, born out of, born out of
Europe, and it may now, uh, for geopolitical and
cultural reasons be drawing in a diff, drawing in
a different direction, which parts company from, uh, from
Europe and, you know, in a sense, uh, sense,
fair enough, you know, geopolitically, uh, that may be
uncomfortable for Europeans, but it also, it also makes
a certain amount of sense. But what I would
say is, In that world in which there is
no longer a West in which Europeans are cozily
sort of uh aligned with America, uh, in that
world, let's take stock of actually where we come
from as Europeans. What defines us as Europeans in
relation to the world? What have our European ancestors
done to impact the rest of the, the world?
You know, why is it that, you know, people
wear, people wear dinner suits and, uh, You know,
I talk about republics and play symphony orchestras in,
in China and all over Africa and the Americas.
Um, YOU know, let's look at that European, uh,
contribution, um. It's, it's Europe that if you like,
did it, even if it also lost it, not,
not the West. I mean, to me, the West
is a kind of, it's a kind of fake
concept. Let's get beyond the West. Let's look at
the whole of the rest of the world, and
then look at Europe's actually quite precarious, but nonetheless,
long lasting impact on that rest of the world.
Great, so let's end on that note then, Dr.
Bitten, and of course your book is again Europe
A New History, and I will be leaving a
link to it in the description of the interview.
And thank you so much for taking the time
to come on the show. It's been a fascinating
conversation. Well,
thank you, Ricardo. I've really enjoyed it too, and
I hope your listeners enjoy it as well.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognun, Machael Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punter Darusmani, Charlotte Blis Nico Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel Pancortezus Suliliski,
Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and Wiseman.
Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke Lovai,
Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams, Dio
Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie Martinez,
Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Jr. Old
Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy, Zigoren,
Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel, Thomas
Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin Gelbert,
Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman. George
Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler, Alexander
Obert, Liam Danaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Jannes
Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean Nelson,
Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks to
my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas Stink, Tom
Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull, Catherine
and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al Nick Cortiz,
and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers, Matthew
Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank you
for all.